hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of modeling the masters
I believe that the fastest and most
effective way to grow a business is to
model the strategies of people who have
already done that what you're trying to
do so today we're going to look at how a
Vietnam vet started two different
businesses and failed but was determined
to become a success and not have to work
for somebody else he would eventually go
on to become one of the most successful
business writers of all time this is the
story of Rich Dad Poor Dad creator
Robert Kiyosaki and the top three
lessons you can learn from his success
Robert Kiyosaki is an American investor
businessman self-help author
motivational speaker and financial
literacy expert best known for his Rich
Dad Poor Dad book series after serving
in the Marine Corps as a helicopter
gunship pilot during the Vietnam War
Kiyosaki returned home to work as a
salesman for Xerox not wanting to work
for someone else for the rest of his
life
Kiyosaki had dreams of starting his own
business after unsuccessful stints
selling velcro wallets and t-shirts for
heavy metal rock bands Kiyosaki began
promoting the personal growth seminars
of marshall thurber called money and
knew when Thurber decided to retire
Kiyosaki took over the business and
began traveling the world to educate
people about financial strategies to
reach more people he decided to write
his first book which he self-published
Rich Dad Poor Dad Robert Kiyosaki is
written over 15 books and is sold over
26 million copies three of his books
have been on the best sellers list of
the Wall Street Journal USA Today and
the New York Times simultaneously and
he's a sought-after speaker who
continues to educate people on how to
understand their money even though
Robert Kiyosaki failed with his first
two businesses he was determined to
become a successful entrepreneur and he
kept at it he tapped into his passion
for teaching people about money and went
on to become more the most successful
business writers of all time to help you
grow your business
here are three action items that you can
learn from Robert Kiyosaki
oxygen atom number one make your money
work hard one bit of advice you to serve
me well with my business is don't spend
money until you're making it anybody can
spend money if I gave you a million
dollars today for your business I'm sure
you can come up with a million different
ways to spend it but not everyone can
make money bootstrapping should be your
mantra find ways to get product or
service out without spending money get
even just a few orders and prove that
people will buy what you're selling then
spend money on expanding your marketing
your money will be well invested because
you know you have something that works
until you start making some sales hustle
and put your sweat in - drumming up some
business
Kiyosaki believes that people go to
school to learn how to work hard for
money while he tries to teach people how
to have money work hard for them he
believes that for many people success is
working hard to lend a secure job at a
big company or government who look after
you until you retire that model might
have worked in the industrial age but
now in the information age people have
to look out for their own financial
security because you can no longer rely
on your employer to take care of you one
of the best ways of doing this he
believes is to create your own business
and become your own boss
according to Kiyosaki the poor and
middle class work for money the rich
have money work for them the rich buy or
create assets that work for them so they
don't have to an asset puts money in
your pocket and a liability takes money
from your pocket the rich understand the
difference and buy assets not
liabilities actually not a number to
mind your own business as entrepreneurs
we have to wear many hats
you're everything from the CEO to the
janitor when you start a business if you
want to grow your business properly and
have confidence in your decision making
you need to understand your numbers yes
it may be boring and outside your core
competencies at the beginning but when
you can understand your balance sheet
income statement and the numbers that
run your business you'll be in a much
better position to drive the company
forward it could be one of the best
investments that you ever make into
yourself and your business if you want
to achieve financial freedom
Kiyosaki believes that there are three
key lessons that you need to master
learn how to make money learn how to
manage it and learn how to invest it
he encourages people to keep their day
jobs until they're earning enough money
on the side or from their own business
or from investments to be able to quit
Kiyosaki also believes that money is a
base subject and that it's never too
late to start learning according to
Kiyosaki many people confuse a
profession with their business to become
financially secure people need to mind
their own business
your business revolves around your asset
column as opposed to your income column
the rich focus on their asset columns
while the poor and middle-class focus on
their income columns action auto number
three work to learn not for money if you
have inserted your business yet a great
piece of advice is to get a job or you
can learn the skills that you need to
succeed as an entrepreneur want to set
up your own auto shop go work for a
small auto shop learn the ins and outs
of how the business runs ask the
business owner to get involved in other
projects in addition to what you're
hired to do work extra hours and on the
weekends to over-deliver
and really understand how the business
works you'll first figure out if that
industry is for you or not and you'll
also make many of your rookie mistakes
while still getting paid by somebody
else
Kiyosaki credits much of his success as
an entrepreneur to his military
education you learn how to lead men into
battle make important decisions quickly
and be tough he translated those skills
and hiring excellent workers and leading
them into business battles he also
credits working for Xerox are teaching
them how to sell and how to accept and
move forward from rejection
according to Kiyosaki many entrepreneurs
fail to grow because they lack
leadership skills and rather than look
in the mirror they find it easier to
blame others blame is short for be lame
and you can't be an effective leader if
you're lame work to learn don't work for
money look for jobs that can help you
develop the skills of managing cash flow
systems and people rather than just pay
you well
so remember make your money work hard
mind your own business and work to learn
not for money to finish up this video I
wanted to share one of my favorite true
stories about Robert Kiyosaki and some
of his best quotes there was once a
friend of Kiyosaki whose
sixteen-year-old son
desperately wanted a new car his friends
had all been given one by their parents
and now this son expected nothing less
but it was not going to be that easy for
the boy his father had played Kiyosaki
his cash flow board game and he wanted
to teach his son a lesson in financial
management the father gave his son
$3,000 but forbade him from using it to
buy a car just yet at the same time he
gave his son a subscription to The Wall
Street Journal the father told his son
that only once he had earned an
additional six thousand dollars from
investments who then used $3,000 to buy
a car
the rest of the money would of course go
to into his college fund my friend said
it was the best three thousand dollars
he ever spent says Kiyosaki not only had
a son gained a new respect for the power
of money he also learned to spend money
wisely instead of letting money burn
holes in his pockets
you
you
you
thank you for joining me for another
dish of modeling masters if you liked
the video and you want to see more
please give it a thumbs up below
I'd also love to hear oh you have to
think if you want to leave a comment
under the video and stay tuned for next
episode
you
you